salut tout le monde on est sur envergure
on est des Français qui parlons de
jeunes basketteurs et qui parlons
spécifiquement cette année des
basketteurs qui vont être ou ne pas être
choisis à la draft NBA 2023 donc pour
intégrer la NBA la saison prochaine on
se concentre sur l'essentiel on fait un
épisode par joueur ce podcast ce sera
l'essentiel sur un dénommé scout
Anderson
scout Anderson né le 3 février 2004
1m889 kilos nous l'avons deuxième dans
notre classement des meilleurs joueurs
ou des meilleurs potentiels de cette
draft dans notre big board deuxième
derrière l'inévitable Victor Wemba nyama
the athletic est d'accord avec nous ils
l'ont le deuxième et il est 3e chez ispn
et weringer derrière Brandon Miller pour
parler de scout underson Hugues et Manu
salut les gars salut salut à toutes
et à toujours bonne nuit
tout ce que vous voulez tout ce que vous
voulez
c'est toi qui commence j'aimerais une
biographie puisque on fait comme ça dans
nos essentiels sur l'essentiel sur scout
Anderson ça commence par savoir par
où il est né quel est quel est son
ascendant voilà qu'est-ce qu'il aime
dans la vie et ben je pense que le truc
le plus important que tout le monde se
demande c'est pourquoi scout andelsen et
j'ai mené l'enquête très loin je suis
allé sur Wikipédia quoi et j'ai vu que
c'est parce qu'il traversait le terrain
comme si il est en train de scout donc
voilà les paroles
et du coup il se dit je m'appelle quatre
patins de Sun donc voilà voilà pourquoi
c'est ça studling il est né il Marietta
Giorgia et donc c'est parents Chris and
crystal undersen moi je me suis dit que
tu vois que tu appelles quiz and cristal
tu dois plutôt Staline mais non ils ont
choisi ils ont choisi un truc un peu
plus un peu plus stylée staling et
il est frère elle a il a 7 enfin il est
dans pardon je vais regarder
je suis prof de matériel faut pas
l'oublier et il est dans une fratrie où
il y a beaucoup de de monde qui fait du
sport il a trois de ses sœurs qui ont
joué en en NCA son papa il est coach
dans gym il est voilà il est dans un
basic-fit sauf qu'elle crée son propre
basique fit et c'est une famille voilà
très sportive très compétitive
et puis on a un garçon qui a été aussi
programmé un professionnel sur le
terrain et puis en dehors c'est un jeune
qui a déjà signé des rencontres avec une
marque de chaussures avec c'est un jeune
qui a déjà créé sa ligue de
développement de jeunes donc c'est fou
il a pas le droit de boire une bière il
a pas mis un pied en NBA mais il a déjà
son camp d'été scooter de Sun donc il y
a une vraie marque qui est développée
autour de lui et ça explique aussi le
choix d'aller Enzy League ça a été un
des premiers donc allez on dit dans la
c'est la night c'est ça c'est la
deuxième saison après la belle réussite
de Jason green parce qu'il a fait 200
c'est sa deuxième année en X night l'an
dernier il était normalement
en développement il était pas attendu
comme le gros prospect ça devait être
jetoner ça devait Tyson Daniels et en
vrai tout le monde sait regarder
healight pour scooter Henderson et
honnêteté on était assez frustré de ne
pas le voir arriver en NBA avant la
cuvée 2023 et puis il fait encore une
deuxième très belle année je vais
laisser Manu en parler qu'est-ce qu'il
faisait Manu cette saison est-ce qu'il
était meneur de jeu
est-ce qu'il prenait des tirs plus au
cercle après pick and roll ou plutôt un
joueur off Ball qui vient en deuxième
lame que quel rôle il avait
offensivement scooter Sun avec laïknight
donc ce qui faisait il joue au basket
déjà c'est un premier élément ce qui est
pas le cas de tout le monde c'est ça que
tu veux dire
et
il avait les rôles de porteur de balle
numéro 1 ce qui est déjà une grosse
différence par rapport à son année 1 en
avec
ou du coup son taux d'usage et passer à
27%
quasiment de neuillocentrisme bon c'est
pas non plus énorme je pensais que ce
serait plus tu me surprends ouais et
c'était un
gars qui avait beaucoup beaucoup la
balle honnêtement
qui se servait de sa force principale
c'est qu'il attaque le panier à fond les
ballons
de beaucoup plus en retrait sur son tir
27% je crois 3 points sur l'année avec
des pourcentages
en montagne russe selon les mois selon
les ce qui est super c'est ce qui est
marrant sur leur site Digg night c'est
qu'on voit qu'il est très très fort
quand il a au moins trois jours de repos
il joue à 43% à 3 points quand il a 3
jours de repos
dommage
10% quand ils jouent à trois points
10% à 3 points quand il a 0 jours de
repos
du gluten le matin ou pas
donc en tout cas plutôt plutôt porteur
de balles c'est ça offensivement et
défensivement quel est le rôle qu'il
avait ce qu'il s'appelle le meneur
adverse est-ce que on le cachait un peu
pour le faire briller en attaque
j'ai bossé un peu des deux c'est pas sa
force principale mais il est quand même
vraiment correct et puis il est vraiment
balèze honnêtement je sais pas ce qu'il
a en envergure d'épaule ça l'a regardé
les sculptés dans la pierre le truc
c'est assez dingue donc il a fait le taf
sans sans plus face à une adversité
totalement autre quand une signait on va
pas se le cacher donc c'est pas c'est
pas la même chose oui on dit meilleur ou
bien meilleur bien meilleur
et après le seul hic de sa saison c'est
uniquement 19 matchs joués sur 32 je
crois de je crois que c'est un peu ouais
je crois que c'est un peu plus de 30
jouets par son équipe lui il en a fait
19 il a été blessé au genou il a eu une
nasale fracture je sais pas ce que c'est
si c'est les voies nasales si c'est le
nez je sais pas trop
une fracture au visage en tout cas et il
a été shut down sur la fin de saison
aussi
pour des raisons qu'on ne dévoilera pas
si on peut le dire pour pas qu'il se
blesse
avant la draft
Hugues pour ceux qui connaissent
vraiment pas parce que il y en a qui ont
pu être introduit à scout Anderson via
le match organisé contre les Metz quand
les mettre sont voyagés pour faire
justement pour créer ce duel en fait
scooter Sun comme Victor
quelle est la force principale pour ceux
qui n'ont jamais vu jouer scooter Sun de
scooter
c'est clairement la pénétration elle est
je parle pas de pornographie loin de là
c'est je suis désolé pour cette human de
panique de bas niveau tu pourras le
couper au montage mais c'est le drive un
jour très explosif notamment dans le
dans le changement de direction très
fort pour attaquer le panier très fort
pour changer de main très fort pour
changer de direction changer de rythme
et puis la définition assez crafter il
est pas très grand mais très tonique il
y a un côté
un peu Derrick Rose dans le dans
l'agressivité près du panier c'est un
fan des boost qui vous dit ça donc ça
montre l'amour que j'ai pour scooter
Anderson et
spectaculaire donc c'est un joueur quand
vous l'avez dans votre équipe vous êtes
vous tombez vite en amour et c'est
difficile de je trouve qu'on a personne
il joue
de regarder autre chose que lui sur le
sur le parquet il y a peut-être des il
va jouer contre des meilleurs joueurs
contre des All Stars et je sais pas si
c'est un très bon argument
basket basket mais marketing m'en
parlant c'est un garçon qui va qui va
attirer attirer beaucoup de regard et
voilà vraiment un vrai fini sur près du
panier tout en étant capable d'apporter
autre chose pour pouvoir ce qu'est son
accès au panier voilà il a assez de
polyvalence il a un C de force dans son
dribble pour
réussir à se créer cet accès en sachant
très bien qu'il veut aller au cercle
Manu est-ce qu'on peut ajouter ce qu'il
a la taille d'un NBA franchement s'il a
pas le ballon je vois pas trop ce qu'il
y a à faire vu son pourcentage à trois
points et vu sa taille
et ce qui peut être intitulaire est-ce
que c'est un playmaker pour les autres
aussi il va mettre les pieds dans la
peinture est-ce qu'il fait les bons
choix ensuite ouais moi j'aime beaucoup
beaucoup bah le doll spacing NBA va
encore plus l'aider à
se lâcher et terminer au cercle mais
c'est aussi un très très bon passeur
moi j'aime beaucoup ça ça capacité à
créer pour les autres plus de 7 plus de
6 pages je crois de mémoire de
moyenne cette année il a quasiment 30%
d'assistes ce qui est haut portrait haut
ouais c'est des vrais pas ce qui sort
c'est pas des c'est pas des passes de
allez hop franchement il est vraiment
intéressant dans la vision du jeu c'est
pour moi le deuxième élément
forte en son jeu c'est c'est vraiment ça
le c'est une vision création des pour
les autres qui est qui est franchement
intéressante et je pense que ça va lui
faire plus que son scoring c'est
vraiment ça aussi cette gestion qui va
pouvoir lui faire gagner des minutes
et oui parce que en plus c'est quelque
chose pour donner du contexte
qui lui est pas qui lui était reproché
mais on disait bon c'est quoi la limite
de scout Anderson après son sa première
année Angie et je disais bon est-ce
qu'il est capable d'être un meneur de
jeu quoi en gros les gens se demandaient
bon bah visiblement on a la réponse Manu
et Hugues je pense tu es d'accord ah
ouais totalement capable de passer dès
demain à une main manipulation visuelle
timing il envoie le ballon là où le
joueur qui reçoit la passe doit être et
pas là où le joueur est donc un œil en
avant c'est ça peut être un chef
d'orchestre en étant à marsupial donc le
combo est incroyable
pour moi c'est vraiment le tir il faut
qu'il arrive à ne serait-ce que s'il
sera forcément ciblé du coup peut-être
un peu de l'espace le défenseur le
laissera un peu d'espace c'est
sanctionné quand il est ouvert déjà rien
que ça à trois points
oui sans devenir un mec qui fait des
step back et tout mais déjà
au début c'est vraiment ça qui
sanctionne à trois points quand qu'on
lui laisse un minimum d'espace et après
avec le temps de venir un vrai shooter
après ce qui m'inquiète c'est son 76% au
lancer franc
qui pour un joueur arrière c'est
vraiment très très faible
ose pas non plus
66 mais on voit par exemple
des joueurs hautes qui sont beaucoup
plus accessibles mais des Branden Miller
ou Jordan Hawkins au hasard
ça ajoute à plus de 80% à au lancer
franc
on va dire au top 10 effectivement sont
plutôt à droite au lancer franc plus à
droite lui-même Victor est très très bon
là-dessus donc c'est vraiment ça moi qui
peut m'inquiéter honnêtement il y a un
vrai problème mécanique sur les lancé
France un geste très saccadé en deux
temps
on voit qu'il y a un monté de balle et
puis après vraiment il l'envoie au
niveau du coude et donc c'est pas
naturel du tout et même son tir pour
pour le pour des classes interdit très
plat
moi je me demande si c'est pas un joueur
de pull-up quoi c'est rare en fait qui
qui va être plus à droite en sortie de
RIP que en kitchen shoot
on a l'impression qu'il est préférence
motrice vont dans ce sens là en tout cas
pour moi c'est quasi sûr que c'est le
cas et
je le vois
pas l'émission je le vois plus efficace
que ce que les chiffres là
nous montrent et que les il y a quelques
matchs alors c'est pas un énorme
échantillon mais quelques matchs sous
les défenses sont passés dessous sous le
piquant de rôle il a réussi les
sanctionner on sait que c'est pas ce
qu'il veut faire mais ça veut pas dire
qu'il ne sait pas le faire et notamment
mi distance moi je suis assez rassuré
par son son poulet de Game om en mi
distance sur les défenses qui vont
vraiment droper il est détruit vraiment
sur le midrail des deux côtés même dans
l'axe et il a la capacité à créer les
cartes donc sur la main dominante step
back et je te poulets pas mis dans la
tête et il le fait vraiment très bien
donc je pense que ça va aller et on voit
des mecs qui arrivent pour des meneurs
athlétiques comme ça comme les diamants
ces dernières années qui répond NBA avec
un petit extérieur très moyen et qui
l'aime des Iron Fox et qui jusqu'en
saison régulière font leur beurre et
c'est déjà très très bien si notre ami
ce côté Henderson est amené à avoir des
difficultés enfin les deux premières
années c'est que ça se passe vraiment
bien pour lui déjà
l'une des choses les plus simples à
travailler
tout à fait oui oui plus que la lecture
de jeu tout ça
meilleur scénario et pour une fois je
vais vous demander une comparaison si
vous l'avez
parce que moi je disais mini Dway night
il est plus petit que
quand je le voyais jouer l'année
dernière est-ce que vous avez des
comparaisons ou en tout cas est-ce que
vous pour vous le meilleur scénario
c'est quoi c'est all star c'est plus que
ça
il est quand même petit c'est rare de
voir des joueurs All-Star aussi petit
il fait en fait un mètre 88 91 et on est
dans la dimension de en termes de taille
des des westbrooks qui fait un 91
dédiéro ce qui fait un 88 des Chris Paul
qui fait 88 au pire des blédo qui fait
1,85 ou 94 donc les petits alors pas
Chris Paul de coulait les petits très
athlétiques qui sont banc de scie en
fait ça ça marche pas trop mal et je
trouve qu'il ressemble pas mal à des
joueurs que j'ai cités là
je
j'ai l'impression d'avoir alors c'est
très élogieux mais du 10 rose dans les
capacités athlétiques et dans la vitesse
et dans le dans la capacité de création
de de son écart sur le prêt du panier et
en même temps dans la gestion dans la
vision de passe quelque chose de bien
plus élaboré ce que Chris Paul fait
alors on n'est pas aussi propre que
Chris Paul on n'est pas aussi
si aérien que Kyros mais on mixe les
deux on prend des
des très bonnes très bonne qualité des
deux et j'aime bien le j'aime bien le
résultat final sans être élite comme les
deux dans leur domaine oui donc ça ça
serait une une baisse qui est scénario
donc on imagine quand même un multiple
star avec cette description pour moi
c'est un truc comme ça qu'elles sont
post dans les tu vois dans ma dans ma
vision du truc je alors peut-être que je
suis
l'année prochaine
je le vois bien être top 5 à son poste
en NBA
Manu
j'aime bien la comparaison Hazebrouck
sauf qu'il est bien meilleur
gestionnaire pasteur que Westbrook mais
en termes de capacité de premier pas ou
là ou d'attaque du panier c'est
oiseau qui est une brute donc il est pas
c'est pas Sam c'est un peu en deçà de ça
mais c'est un petit mixte quoi de de ça
j'aime beaucoup aussi le nom de en
termes d'évolution dans le jeu d'un
escalier que c'est diarrons Fox ou c'est
pareil il y avait une vraie capacité de
d'aller au Cercle une vraie rappelle
rapidité de premier pas en sortant de
Kentucky et on avait un peu peur du tir
et c'est un peu pareil que lui il était
assez bon à mi distance on le voyait
déjà ce petit shoot helbo midi chez Fox
qu'il a développé qui est maintenant
quasiment devenu létale dans son jeu et
il commence à reculer à 3 points et
quand on voit la c'est cette année ou
non je sais pas son pourcentage à trois
points mais franchement il en il a
vraiment super bien artillé et s'il peut
avoir cette évolution là en fait
vraiment se stabiliser sur le mid range
et petit à petit s'écarter et ce que je
disais au tout début c'est sanctionner
quand il est ouvert à trois points
tout en gardant cette capacité de vision
de passe de ta table du cercle de
finition au cercle qui qui est quasiment
déjà élite qui lui force sans doute l'un
des meilleurs de sa draft
pour moi un minima c'est un All-Star
la comparaison une fois que c'est sympa
j'aime bien
Fox en cas beaucoup mangé de poulet quoi
ouais ouais il est passé il est passé en
labo mais
c'est vraiment dans l'évolution j'ai
trouvé le nom
tout à fait sur le sur l'attitude est-ce
qu'il y a des choses à redire ou est-ce
que comme Hugh le présentait dans au
début c'est déjà un pro qui a toutes les
attitudes qu'il faut du professionnel
moi j'ai
quelques souvenirs je j'espère pas me
tromper ou c'est un peu des attitudes
bizarres des fois sur le banc
j'ai des trucs comme ça sur le justement
on en parlait aux en parler au tout
début aussi sur les matchs d'exhibition
contre contre les métropolitanes ou des
fois aussi c'était pas fou fou
que ce soit sur le terrain ou sur le
banc
après je gratte un peu mais globalement
il a quand même eu un bon un bon truc
mais je pense qu'il a déjà un mental de
en fait il sait qu'il est bon et il
attend il attend la NBA en fait oui ça
donne un peu cette impression vu que tu
as le même feeling ouais puis ce qui est
cool je trouve que tu vois l'an dernier
sortait du bon parce qu'il savait qu'il
allait pas leur NBA que la Ligue Night
est une vitrine pour envoyer les joueurs
en NBA et ce n'est pas plein il a pas il
a pas essayé de gratter les ballons j'ai
donné Daniel's et d'autres gars il a il
voilà il a il a suivi le scénario il a
laissé faire le truc et ça montre aussi
que
il y a un gars c'est altruiste on aurait
pu penser dans ce contexte Jedi là il
prennent tout et puis se disent bah je
suis juste meilleur que vous et je m'en
tape et je prends tout et il a su
attendre son tour donc je trouve ça
assez cool et bon ça me fait toujours
voilà c'est le bon professionnel dans le
sens où il sait très bien qu'il va être
numéro 2 numéro 3 en tout cas qui sera
pas numéro 1 mais l'âge des déclin en
mode j'ai envie de construire une vraie
une baisation dans Antonio tu vois il y
a le il est déjà stéréotypé il veut pas
admettre qu'il sera pas numéro 1 alors
que tout le monde sait qui sera pas
numéro 1 voilà
le critiquerait encore plus durement
peut-être s'il accepte d'être derrière
quoi d'augmentality
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je voulais vous faire dire
le contexte
de l'année prochaine
en gros pour lui sera sans doute soit
Charlotte soit Portland ou
un trade pour Portland
est-ce que ce que c'est pas un peu
redondant dans un cas comme dans l'autre
bah il y a beaucoup de gens qui se
disent qui peut glisser parce que c'est
Charlotte en deux et qui a la méloball
et on se dit bah c'est pas compatible
les deux c'est des gros bollander moi je
suis je suis pas un cas là dessus d'une
part parce que quand tu es dans une
équipe un peu claquée ben alors au-delà
du fait que prendre le meilleur
potentiel mais tu peux très bien jouer
chacun à son tour et la méloball est un
excellent passeur est-ce que Anderson
j'aime bien son jeu loin du ballon alors
il en a pas eu tant que ça et on préfère
ballonnement évidemment mais quand on
l'a vu sur des situations de démarquage
dans du cut etc il a été vraiment très
bon aussi et je pense pas que ce soit
pour lui un incompatible pendant deux
trois ans donc
ici Charlotte le prend en deux et pour
moi il faut le prendre en deux enfin il
y a dans mon monde
à une Range d'écart un gros tiers
d'écart entre le scout en deux et les
autres derrière je suis pas totalement
ok sachant que ils ont le ils ont le
pivot Mark William peut faire les écarts
ils ont des ailiers alors on verra si
mal prises arrête de tabasser des des
copines mais ils ont pidgy Washington
etc donc moi j'aime beaucoup et j'espère
que Charlotte va pas faire l'impasse
vraiment je je les insulterai très
fortes dans ma tête si jamais ils
prennent pas ce que tu as une personne
en deuxième position c'est ce que
j'écrivais dans le dernier big board
s'il y avait une équipe qui peut faire
l'impasse je sais pas si sur Big board
sur Twitter s'il y a bien une équipe qui
peut faire l'impasse c'est Charlotte qui
est pas connu pour
rester très correctement même si avec la
mélo c'est bien passé mais bon après
c'est pas les mêmes genres de joueurs
la mélo a un plus un maestro
de loin scout va davantage mettre les
pieds dans la peinture va davantage
apporter en transition aussi moi je
l'attends beaucoup là-dessus l'année
prochaine
je prends un rebond je traverse le
terrain je provoque la faute où je où je
décale un type quoi
et
s'ils sont tous les deux assez altruiste
pour jouer l'un avec l'autre et que la
mélo rentre bien s'étire
why not why not
une chose à ajouter messieurs je crois
avoir compris que vous y croyez tous les
deux c'est la question traditionnelle de
fin mais on y croit non
c'est un gros oui
plutôt même si les contexte des équipes
ou les potentiellement draftable ou sera
drafté pas ouf sur le papier ce jour-là
du 25 mai
je pense qu'il va réussir il peut plus
réussir en fait c'est une superstar en
devenir oui peut-être que ça buggera un
peu à cause de de problèmes de
management enfin en tout cas
si on le draft il faut le faire jouer
quoi il faut lui mettre le ballon entre
les mains ça je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord là-dessus pour si on draft
aussi en tout cas et quand on a un top 3
de piquant dans le top 3 ou une raft
pour on vise la lune donc voilà c'était
notre essentiel merci Hugues merci Manu
et notre essentiel sur scout Anderson
mes autres podcasts sur toutes les
plateformes sur ce podcast sur les
autres prospects de cette draft NBA 2023
leur fiche et leur scouting reporte à
l'écrit sur envergure point co salut
tout le monde